all right how welcome you I welcome you
all here and clear the meeting open yet
Thank You counselor and just so you know
what we're actually doing this evening
there's be some changes you'll be asked
to consider as we as we go through
firstly will be when we get after the
minutes met as a rising we have kiddie
Waghorn here we asked for information
with the customary cycling and could
he's here to table that or give us that
and when she's done that and you've
asked questions of we'll move over
straight to item 8a II under
correspondence and we'll receive that
officially the air because that it
appears twice on their gender Kitty your
up front but don't it doesn't need to
bother you just so members know where we
are going there and then we'll go back
to the normal and we'll come back to
Part B of eight later in the meeting
also we have to deputations tonight
we've got met bacon talking about the
sitting back there met to talk about the
quarry as we asked the last meeting and
we've got Trevor right to talk about
landscape budget and he's got some ideas
and I met with staff and Trevor at
Milton Reserve the other day so it's
something for you to consider it's it's
quite a complicated issue and we'll just
deal with it when we get there but just
so you know that we are looking at other
alternatives as well as the
recommendation at this stage for you to
consider it and make a decision on so
again welcome apologies we have apology
from Kirsten move I'll move accepted
Duncan has seconded it all those in
favor please say aye
contrary carry any conflicts of interest
appear to be none
minutes have been circulated are there
any Corrections appear to be none
so someone prepared to move the adoption
of the minutes move by Paul segment by
Jason I'll put that all those in favor
please say aye the country carried
matters arising will have already
commented the first one is that cust
recycling facilities so kitty a few
would like to come forward and table
your report and talk to it and there may
be some questions I'll I'll circulate a
a full report to the community board
shortly - the next day or so won't be
received no you won't be receiving
tonight haven't quite finished that the
publicly available copy that's right but
the hazardous waste working party met
this afternoon or this evening to
consider the report on the cust
community facility and they have
approved reinstating the trial for up to
another six months and we have said that
all going well we could reinstate that
in August and run it to the end of
January mainly we know it was a success
and that we got a good amount of
recycling the quality was good
there was good community buying and the
community wants it back what we don't
have is all of the all of the kinks
worked out of the system so we were
still having some issues with the
cardboard recycling bins that we had
replaced those who removed within a week
of being installed so we don't know how
those new bins were going to work so so
it'll be a reconstitution of the trial
with some improvements yes yes so we
want to see how that goes and it's it's
up to six months to see how it goes
thrown into the mix we have changed our
plastics recycling so we want to keep an
eye on the contamination or the
potential kinetic contamination from non
acceptable plastics and see whether we
can work through those with the
community hopefully they'll be buying
and people will accept those changes but
that that's something I know that other
councils are struggling with in hurinui
are actually withdrawing some of the
mixed plastics our mixed recycling
drop-off points in just accepting glass
I don't know if you want to ask me any
more questions so if you well thank you
very much for coming and we'll get your
report and will ratify
receiving it at the next meeting clearly
so Thanks thanks kitty that's great
right deputations and presentations the
boards will aware of the and there's
been some publicity in the papers of the
proposed quarry on the racecourse and we
asked for met to come and speak to us
tonight because this is something the
board will I would imagine
definitely need a position on met
welcome excellent thank you and thank
you for having me tonight so what I
thought I'd do is just to run through
very briefly the process for the for the
quarry application from Taggarts
earthmoving and just before I do that
I'm assuming that everyone's aware of
what that application essentially
entails there's been good coverage in
the paper with a mess map of the
racecourse and where they're going to
quarry and the bands around the road and
not money yeah were you gonna hear it
and ask questions okay yeah sure okay so
and what I do have is just unfortunately
don't have enough copies but I have a
summary of the proposal that our
planning team have put together on the
basis that we knew that we were going to
get a few questions on this one and we
certainly have done so what I'll do is
I'll make sure they're circulated around
afterwards but essentially the the
application is
really - Cory application a quarry metal
from the ringer racecourse and so if you
can vision the racecourse it's
essentially the the middle of the
smaller track and and the area to the
north of the within the within the
larger track that goes around the
outside that quarrying is estimated to
be between six hundred thousand cubic
meters and 750 thousand cubic meters of
material and it's over a 15 year period
within those areas and so that works out
to be on average forty to fifty thousand
tonnes per annum and essentially that
that material is intended to go to the
Coens Road site the tickets have for for
processing from there in terms of in
terms of the details so the the proposed
hours of operation are from 7:00 a.m. to
6:00 p.m. Monday to Friday and 7:00 a.m.
to 3:00 p.m. on Saturdays and there's no
no works on Sundays or public holidays
and and the works are sort of dependent
on demand as well so there'll be peaks
and troughs of operations that that's
required in terms of vehicle movements
cutting is approximately 120 loads per
day so that probably gives a really
brief summary of the application and as
I say I'll send around a full of
summaries as well so we received the
application on the 9th of April this
year and that came and obviously during
the covert time and it was version 6 of
the application I believe we so we send
it back a number of times for for
further information we set up the
application we have you we are using an
external processor to process that
consent and that's partly around the
fact that the majority of our staff
actually live in or around Regnerus so
we just wanted to make sure there
weren't any perceived conflicts of
interest there and that that planning
officer is actually so the arraignment
is to make a recommendation back to the
council and then on the notification of
the of the application and the
to make the substantive decision on the
application as well depending on whether
the notification process goes so we have
sent to the application back under what
we call a section 92 request than that
that really means that we've sent it
back for a number of pieces of further
information and that information request
is actually fairly detailed so we've
asked for some more information on
volumes of material where the clean
fills coming in in any rehabilitation
that's being done the nature of
equipment that's going on-site some
further detail on how the vehicle
movements are broken down some further
detail on the hours of operation and
just what the peaks and troughs actually
mean and in practice with us some
question around interface with the
transmission lines lighting of the the
car in any clear for for the winter
months when they're operating noise and
some flooding issues as well so that is
a fairly lengthy and detailed further
information request what we have also
done is we have the so there's a noise
report as part of the application and we
have that peer reviewed as well and so
that's part of the the process going
forward we understand from Taggarts that
they're looking to return that
information as soon as they can our
anticipation is that'll likely take them
at least two to three weeks it's been on
it's been actually on hold for for about
a month now already in this probably
sums up a little bit of the complexity
of the information that we've we've
actually asked for once we get that
information back we need to make a
notification decision obviously on that
on the application and I probably can't
comment too much on where that
applications going to go because we
don't actually have the full information
that we need to make a decision on the
application but but what I would say is
the application assessment of a fix
itself actually does signal that there
are likely to be effects on on
individuals and that is a fairly rare
thing for an app content to
put in their application so that
probably gives a little bit of a signal
around we're that that's likely to go
and so what we will do is we will make
sure that when we're at the point where
we can make a decision that we will
communicate that around and I'm happy to
update the board as well so that's
really a summary of where we're at and
going forward I suppose I can't answer
the the key question that's on
absolutely everyone's mind as to how we
are going to process this application
but that will certainly come as we as we
go through the process a little further
just the only other thing I'd probably
add before I'm happy to take any
questions is just to note we have had
quite a lot of feedback and that's not
unexpected to be to be honest so we
continue to receive sort of a call it
informal feedback on on that and it's
fair to say that it's fairly heavily
weighted on the not wanting the quarry
side of things
excellent so I'm happy to take any
questions around from these boards
perspective we will be able to submit an
objection if we want to the process I
presume so on the presumption that we
are notifying the application and that's
a full notification in the board would
be able to make a submission right and
you will let us know what the timetable
for that is and when we need to have it
in by in due course will you absolutely
so so on the presumption again that we
do fully notify what we'll do is we'll
make sure that a copy of the application
and that letter goes direct to the board
and that'll have the the timeframes for
submission there's a there's a 20
working day time frame so there's a
there's a reasonable amount of time to
provide and is there any likelihood or
risk from our perspective that it won't
be fully notified I think of the quarry
issue previously it's been two hours and
yeah I so really difficult for me to
come in of course get because because we
don't have that information to go
forward I would say that the difference
between the quarry the Spencer Bauer
quarry that eventually did go through
was that that was actually surrounded
albeit by
small a lot rural zone but it was a
rural zoning this one is obviously on
the on the bounds of of an urban
environment and it's a fairly rare
scenario to have a quarry in located in
that location so I think that yes there
is always a possibility that the
consumer doesn't get notified but there
are certainly as I said there are some
some indicators within the application
itself there are some of weeks to
consider questions from members Paul
just to query
you mentioned 143 truck and trailer
movements per day sit just taking stuff
out there's not filling it back in so
does that sort of double so yeah it's a
hundred and twenty more movements per
day there so that what that includes any
material that they bring back in but
they don't bring it back in at the same
time and they take it out of if it makes
sense so they're that three shoulder of
a hundred and twenty movements is
designed effectively to come under our
threshold of the district plan and
that's certainly one of the questions
we've asked the other sort of question
that we have is what happens to the
other movements that we that you can't
consider so for example if the trucks
broke down and you need vehicles to come
in and service them or you have other
events at the racecourse how does that
tie in so that's certainly one of the
questions we've asked another question
is when they've got a big hole if they
get a big hole in the ground how quickly
or soon would that have to be filled on
the siddur
some other time frankly knows that and
that hole we lived here for twelve
months before they follow done or has
any indication on it there's some
flexibility around that now and they
called they have different campaigns so
they don't sort of open the whole thing
at once they open it open it and chunks
I understand the intention is that they
will as they open parts of it then
they'll rehabilitate those as they're as
they're doing the next the next part but
that's certain
we're with us for some further
information because effectively that's
going to be the thing that lasts and
perpetuity after the after the quarry is
done so we want to ensure that we we
understand fully what they're intending
to do further questions
can I just clarify I'll come to you many
the truck movement that Paul arson 120
movements is that a truck going in empty
and coming out loaded or would that be
240 truck movements because it'd be
actually different movements onto River
Road wouldn't it that's that's quite
right so the the summary I have here
sees approximately 120 loads a day and
the way that our brain works there to do
actually be 240 that's what I thought I
just carry Monique you had a question
you down any question oh yeah
the only question all done Monique I'm
just curious why they chose that site
because surely they're imagining there's
going to be quite a bit of resistance is
there something particularly special
about that location it's fair to say I'm
feeling curious as well one of the
people that I spoke to summed it up
quite well it's it's a very odd site to
be chosen
I'm not entirely sure I would imagine
that it's because it's got some good
material and it's very close to the
coins Road Depot but they haven't seen
as much I think if you read the paper it
wouldn't be unfair to say the trotting
club president stated quote publicly
that Racing's not making any money at
the moment so they see that as a way of
generating income for their industry so
I think it's a very willing so that's
been publicly in the papers I'm not
saying anything Underwood
Marie I'm just judging by the complaints
about quarries and other districts dust
control was seen to be one of the major
issues that we would have as local
residents dearly and they would need to
have some decent dewatering equipment
installed or spray equipment to come a
the part stockpiles
correct and one of the things I didn't
didn't say is that there's a there's a
knee cane consent as well going through
at the same time when and we actually
have the same processor working on both
consents and and certainly dust in dust
mitigation and silicates and all of
those things will be live matters for
both concedes Morris it could it be
concerned to the council that if this
was approved and they started extracting
shingle from the race course that other
outfits are working in Ashley River near
may exit the river is it were possibly
easier to get the shingle from other
places in the river a my concern there
is that we actually need shingle taken
out of the river to keep the river
should be flowing it's a great really
good question so in planning terms
that's what's timid person and effect so
if you get a consent for one activity
does that then follow that other
activities that are similar shouldn't
should also be able to do that and that
is dead as a live matter and we cover
that off with with with all consents
what what I probably would say is when
you get two consents of this scale it
would be very hard to argue that each
one is similar enough to another one to
then trigger it to be treated in the
same way because they have a
wide-ranging list of effects so it
certainly is a matter that we need to
consider but but as I say it's it's
probably it wouldn't necessarily lead to
if we granted this consent that other
that other consent should and would be
granted here does the planning process
near weight conservation values in the
process and we can think of some of the
conservation values within the issue
repeat in obviously it's never
organizations ring or have funded that
the savings of the gaol
the boots but in the area is there a
process by now which those conservation
you they waited as to how they might go
in the process it's another another good
question so the decision is made based
primarily on the objectives and policies
of the district plan and they don't so
there's no specific policy that talks
about and in the district plan that
talks about conservation areas of the
issue over and things now there are some
policies around significant vegetation
and those sort of things and they're
generally actually gorge and those sort
of things but there is also the need to
consider any other national direction
documents and so we've got some
biodiversity strategies and
what-have-you that have come out and
also some provisions within the regional
policy statement particularly around
biodiversity and what-have-you so so
they are certainly matters that that are
considered in effect section 104 as
there is the section of the Act that
that we make decisions on and that
actually also has a quite a neat in
handy provision in it which is called
any other matter that committed the
decision-making considers necessary so
that then allows a bit of a weighting
argument to come in and certainly those
matters are really important to consider
so I think the answer is not explicitly
but implicitly there is the ability to
consider further questions all right
Matt thank you very much that's very
helpful when will I know you'll keep us
informed
excellent and while I've got the floor
just really briefly I'm happy if there
are any other applications that you're
looking for an update on through through
that year I'm happy to come along and
give an update or certainly provide a
written update as well thank you very
much right so now we invite him Trevor
Wright to come forward and talk to us
about his thoughts welcome to River
you've got ten minutes if you like us to
turn your little light on and stay
seated and
comfortable fact it's been said that our
garden has never die they just go to
seed so with it thought on seed Ralph
Waldo Emerson said so a thought in your
even act and what I'm here to do tonight
is to try and so a thought and for you
folks
I've lived in rain you or now for five
years and observe what Community Design
is happening and it seems odd to me as
one or two of you've heard me say before
that a town bordering on City size
doesn't ever prescribe land or play
piece of land or planned set in place
for a botanic type garden by botanic
type I don't mean the strict sense but I
was just saying the other day when I was
a kid I recall plants having you know
specific names written on them and that
those names took my fancy in all my life
so the seed thought is and concerning
Milton Park which has that triangle by
the bridge you've got Milton Avenue down
one side we've got Cohen's Road and
you've got a dog park and dark and so on
along River Road
we've been I've been looking for a space
that would represent this view and I
figure that this reserve would be a
suitable place to to develop this and I
would see not native trees but
non-native ones deciduous ones framework
trees in the theoretic names on for
strange little fellas like me that like
to see the name there are many specific
and general plants plantings of native
surrendering or and
I would like to see and this garden as
being something different the
establishment of the trees would need
some considerable care for the first few
years so they became properly
established the Christchurch Botanic
Gardens our coastal gardens and they are
totally different to what we have here
as I've discovered we have hotter draw
our summers and as you may be aware we
have freezing cold nights in the winter
and so the planting choices that need to
be different beautiful lawns are not
part of the consideration it was
suggested that it might not even be
called a botanic garden but perhaps an
arboretum or a park set aside in this
style there could be though potential
for some experimental plantings and when
we lived in Dunedin I managed a place
called the new crop center and we had
all sorts of plantings which we trialed
and then we had open days when we showed
people what we had and some of those
plants were taken up commercially and
added to the richness of the area and I
recall when my folks used to live here
no burn was a an area of horticultural
plantings not quite so these days the
area I reckon is around about seven and
a half hectares which would take a fair
number of plants and I understand
talking about seed you may have some
seed funding just have a think of this
if you had a thousand plants which would
retail it perhaps $50 and you'd get them
for $25 wholesale plus Freight but
that's thirty-five thousand just like
that would they have any other costs so
it's not a small project that I'm
proposing but I think it's absolutely
essential because we're not making any
more land we
building lots of houses and schools and
things around the area and it won't be
long for this no available land and I
consider that no reserve would be very
suitable for that it's an amongst all
the other recreational type things in
the local area so it would fit in with
those have you got any questions
questions Monique I was wondering if you
would consider it as a memorial park
that people you know could gift
trees to help with caustics you could do
anything to keep the cost down there's
quite a large park like that in Rotorua
which works quite efficiently and also
maybe yes some of them yeah so some
fruit trees do find in the area
and others don't for example walnuts do
marginally well but often we get a late
frost that hits the flare so we'd have
to be selective but I was just saying to
the guys the other day I think I would
plant the selection of cornice along
next to the dog pack the common name for
cornices dogwood so not many people
would enjoy that play on words but and I
think that some of the fruiting trees
would be quite suitable I would like to
see for example up Milton Avenue because
it's an avenue and there's no trees to
speak of I would like to see that as
almond trees planted right up there on
that side of the road they they're the
first blossom flowers in the spring and
so they say Here I am someone's coming
you know and I would think seeing as how
that's one of the increase to rain you
or there would be a nice thing to have I
don't think the board should get too
worried at what would go in the Oh may
go in the other stage should should the
board
wish to go down that road it would be a
council managed and controlled plantings
and developments and they may very well
talk to mr. right at the same time so it
would be bored when you pull up what you
just hit yet would you be interesting a
sort of a volunteer group to and look
after it and you know Milken Eve okay
Nick group to organize though we sort of
a a group of gardeners and what he would
look after it and do the planting and
keep the costs down for the council
would that type of thing you'll be
thinking of it would have to be under
council control in my opinion and so
whatever you can get away with it's fine
yeah I had contact from so there may be
groups that would like to help the
council maybe other people trees to this
effort but I would think that the trees
would have to be on a landscape design
which was agreed by council Murray you
consume me about the thing is that we
don't end up building something or
constructing something that ends up
being an almost cost of green space
which means it'll eventually flow
through to rates which council Williams
just mentioned and that would be a worry
to me if it was too big that would be a
problem because I've tried very hard to
keep the right stand up here and that's
not going to help so volunteer voluntary
looking after it would probably be a
good way carrying it in yes
but eventually knowing the way things
work a council department would take it
over
just listening um we do have a volunteer
group whether beautifying people and
they do a great job of all sorts of
areas and it might be the partnership
with them I think I like your idea of
the doubles and and I think maybe it's a
partnership
might be nice within talk to those
people and see if you can get something
going with them and you know see if we
can support you a long way that was is
that from maintenance you're talking
about
no just thought for planting for doing
the whole thing I guess the council have
to approve you some of the plan
so I if you wanted to sort of maybe get
together with them and and talk to them
and say and come up with a plan and
probably for the council to make the
space available if that's appropriate
and then go from there because they've
done a wonderful job I know they do a
great job done Lance unworried they've
done a great job keeping it clean and
tidy and you know and so they're very
good people which you might enjoy
whatever the Board considers later would
it would always come back will always
come back to the board for final plans
final approvals costs and maintenance
and other issues would be discussed
later when we were on-site here with
Grant McLeod and Grant Stevens Stevens
the the other day they both observed
that the council had been contemplating
this for some time and had some monies
put aside which of course have come out
of the budget with cost savings for this
coming year but such costs as mowing
there would be no need for example to
mow that two lawn standard if you look
just south of the dog back you'll see
it's just Mon and looks very tidy and so
those sort of approaches could be quite
feasible just an answer to the question
raised other questions all right well
thank you very much and for the board's
information Trevor
is also involved and instigated helped
instigate the plantings at the end of
flexed and rode at the the ponds down
there so we appreciate the work and you
thought that you put in so thank you
very much for coming along you okay
they don't require me anymore no no okay
you can go but we will be debating if
you want to stay the general landscape
budget which this could be part of or
may not be part of we'll see where it
gets to in just a few moments why not
okay
my only coming to you yeah I would
possibly be I think it's quite a nice
spot that nobody should underestimate
the cost of establishment because green
space don't normally water trees but
it's a very stony sort of arid Southern
so in the public go past so I'm a
perception point of view it's gotta be
pretty well cleaned out for to be
nothing worse than the whole heap of
trees dying out there so that question
was raised on site and grant McCloud
said it wouldn't be too difficult to put
watering holes down with individual
plantings so good point Duncan right all
right Trevor I think thank you it right
well we'll move on to item 7.1 the
general landscaping budget pages 21 to
31 and we've got Ryan so thank you right
think you are so I'll just gotta
introduce myself i'm rana Lockland I'm
part of the green space team so tonight
I am just covering for grants demons and
grant MacLeod who have some meeting
commitments they have to attend to so
this report is regarding the general
landscaping budget so following a
workshop with the community board in
December last year grant Stephens is
going away and prepared the following
report around the 11 projects that were
identified from that workshop these
projects have all been summarized on
page 30 including the costs and the
staff recommendations they're the
current budget available to the board is
fifty six thousand and sixty one dollars
however it's noted here that in a
previous meeting the board has made a
verbal commitment of seven and a half
thousand dollars to complete the rainy
return entrance on one side row this
would mean that the board has forty
eight thousand five hundred sixty one
dollars yet to be allocated within this
financial year This report provides the
board with information regarding the
costs opportunities implications of each
of the projects and recommends
allocation towards four of the eleven
projects with the resting on the list
there's potential future projects and as
the chair has mentioned the board may
want to consider the deputation just
previously as part of this consideration
of the budget if you're taking any
questions on this report right can you
tell me I started off how rugby one set
a rugby post could cost $4,000 two posts
across bearer in a hockey net behind
$4,000 I just don't understand it which
does not have to I won't stick him in
I'm asking the question I don't know the
answer I wouldn't know the exact cost of
it but I know grant Stephens would have
based it on the previous costs that we
have used in the past I know there was a
set of post put and at the points
oval which was a single set of posts
which is the communities I think it
would include the installation cost as
well as
thing of the piece of equipment
questioned other question pool why one
is poo pod big $1,200 for a obscene idea
they're just a wee square metal
container with rolls of plastic bags in
them right $1,200
again that would be based on ones that
we've previously in store throughout the
district soapy based on recent costs or
previous course it with Monique I made
the suggestion of the table tennis table
and I see the comment was made that
supplied bats and balls etc and I
thought you know we put up gold posts
and we don't supplied meatballs
I'd never envisioned that they would
have to supply table tennis bets and
balls for the for a public they were
Tina's table so I thought it was a bit
of a study I mean to put on there and I
thought it would be quite perfect to be
outdoors thank you I can definitely pass
it feedback on to Grant Stevens and get
something for the board to consider and
window deliberate on the recommendations
could you in light of the presentation
we just had from mr. right
could you inform us what work has been
done on Milton area I know from meeting
the other day that the council green
space has been considering the adoption
for some time and I understand you have
some budgets and in the years ahead to
do it that could you explain what the
proposal my may be there or may not be
there so we know before we get on and
the second part of that question why
haven't we been told or consulted on
that so my understanding in regards to
Milton
is that a development of the master plan
or the implementation of their master
plan will be going forward with the
budget allocation so in the 2021
financial year they're a city 1760
dollars and twenty one twenty two there
is seventy five thousand five hundred
and fifty and in twenty three twenty
four there is 25,550 available so in
terms of implementation at there that
would depend on the overall master plan
and how they but the first thirty one
thousand come out has it not it's in
this current financial yet was it taken
out for your budget reductions I
understand sorry there's eighty 1760 in
this current financial year there's part
of the covert review of the in your plan
budget fifty thousand that was pushed
into next financial year so they still
remains thirty one thousand seven
hundred sixty dollars this financial
year right any other questions Paul and
in Syria one question of we were down
consumed approved the allocation of four
thousand to even practice rugby posts
being installed at the Cass domain
subject to the approval of the Custer
main Advisory Board surely they would be
the ones asking for the needed of Wragby
posts before we would say we should be
putting rugby posts in there this is the
chicken and eggs scenario
omishi unsure of how that specific
project was raised with the board
whether I come from a member of the
community to the board or whether it was
for the advisory group for the customer
but I'm saying has got subject to the
approval of the custom main board so if
they asked for it I wouldn't be subject
to the approval I would imagine I'm just
a wee bit unsure of where there was a
community board member who was raised
the project through the community board
process or whether it was the advisory
group erase the pruno didn't come from
here didn't go may have come from a
member of this board but it hasn't come
from the board
Sara so just it's you know might I'll be
getting it right but as their 31,000
available this year to do something with
Milton and we've just had Trevor talkin
about what he'd like to do is this
Kinect Kinect and why something that can
be done the choice is up to the board
it's got suggestion here is to put
thirty thousand towards next and rode
the board could put that to muten if it
was of a mind because flex and Road as
development hasn't started here at this
stage so that's up to the board serious
okay
other questions alright okay you want to
make some comments I just wanted to give
a little bit of background in regards to
the entrance offering your projects that
were considered originally for
beautification which I think was last -
I've done a little bit of research on
children's request and I just wanted to
donate the other board members who
weren't here more aware of the situation
so a good decision can be made
originally the the board decided on to
concentrate on three of the regular
entrances that they considered at that
time to be a priority
Lance Arad was obviously number one
which is just about complete
Kippenberger Avenue which had issues and
still sort of up in the air and pull a
can come up with a decision about
undergrounding and Oxford Road which
which was they but I think the board
felt that the traffic movement wasn't
really sufficient to spend a lot of
money on it
at this point it's uh it's actually
listen the traffic has lessened because
of the Lehman's riled and Western
which was deviated some of the traffic
that used to come down that road flex
didn't Road surprisingly enough was
never ever actually a consideration and
it was only at the end of last year when
routing brought a report about a lot of
routing improvements that were going to
happen around flex turn Road with the
inclusion of a walkway and soccerway
that there was any sort of discussion
about beautifying that area and the
board sort of was asked would they
consider giving some money on of the
landscaping money to tidy up the place
after the road works had been completed
so I think it's been quite a surprise
for some of the board members to
suddenly find their flex generators is
almost a fighter company for 30,000 and
I think I just wanted to give you that
background so that you know it isn't it
was never really decided so feel free to
change if you want to that routing
project probably might crop up again and
you can then consider it at that time
but it seems silly to to do that work
now and then with the chance of it all
being dug up at a later stage and also
you must remember that that fern side
flexed and Road intersection is going to
have major works on there which may
impact on what you want to do lower down
question got a question for the
achievement if we can answer this and
maybe keep going with the REC view post
is it part of the budget of the
landscaping system with you know rec
view posts coming out of the landscaping
budget would that mean well it's to
beautify and make we've never had a
request I can't actually answer that to
be quite honest normally we are on green
space and greenery and trees and parents
and shrubbery and beautification and you
know Robbie we've never normally that
posts would come up under discretionary
grants budget I would have thought
I don't know about the physical works
effects in road I don't know where it's
it I think only the counselors would
know that yeah isn't it on delay while
the walking cycling strategies being
finalized before they decide whether
they want to put a track down
that area I think that's where the delay
is coming in we just accept what Kay
says is correct right I think just
before we have any more questions this
is a very important decision the board's
going to make if we put thirty thousand
somewhere and rather than just have a
motion
we might get a lot but we've it lost
would you be quite happy if we moved
into workshop mode and we just discussed
the items and then sort of get a
consensus and we could get a motion to
unum I'm in your hands but what what's
your view everyone's quiet okay okay
move move and see can we go into
workshop all those in favor please say
aye
the country carry be tidy and it would
have a good future because a town the
size of bring you or need something of
there somewhere I don't know where but
that's there so that that is obviously a
possibility as I see it and flex and
Road to me I think it's too soon to make
any judgments on flexed and Road I don't
know what it's going to look like when
it is finished I don't know what traffic
there is going to do because once you
get the the roundabouts on flexed and
fern side the roundabouts what he was
going there correct knee counts as if I
got it wrong on fern side Townsend at
Townsend improved culverts improved and
lower down sticks bridge done something
to a lot of traffic coming into regular
that way may vary will deviate route I
don't know and I just think it's too
soon and I don't know what flex and
roads going to look like when that's
finished I don't think anyone here
really knows because we haven't
contemplated putting that sort of meant
so so that's on those things when it
comes to the other issues will should we
deal with that one first that's really
the thirty thousand I've started that
also so to interrupt you can you correct
me Dan psmith offered to fund the trees
and everything that Trevor Wright talked
about around the retention pond at the
corner and he's done there his two
hundred and fifty thousand initial was
for piping and it was tagged two piping
the drain at that stage okay well I
accept what you say
well we're out got the idea that it has
been delayed it's because from what I
understood the concentration was going
to move towards the fern side area and
the lower area which they were
considering with the heads would not
disappeared but it had been put on hold
because until they knew what was
happening up at the top - then put
soccer ways and walkways and things down
that road happy was in abeyance until
the walking and cycling strategy thing
but I couldn't be wrong out there that
was just my understand I also don't
think it makes much difference to the
argument here as to whether us going
here this year or next year I'm sure if
it was delayed it's only short-term Rob
yeah but we don't know much about what
it look like this is finished yeah Joan
yes I think there's too much happening
and feeling aside at the fin side flexed
and rode we're doing a roundabout down
there there's a lot to happen a lot of
disruption to happen and and it would be
my personal view it's we delay spending
any money until there's more surety and
if we've got 30,000 we might be better
to put it elsewhere in the meantime
until we know exactly what's happening
and Kay's rights there's there's a new
group of cycling walking and there's
been someone who submitted to the
council from a hooker that wants a cycle
way from a hooker through and through
and touring Europe and I guess that's
what I'm not involved in it but I guess
that's on on the and the pipeline as
well so I I think and I know that um I
wasn't at the meeting but Paul was at
the meeting where there was one of the
lady from North Canterbury News Shelley
Todd had a meeting asked me to go and I
couldn't go she wants to do a in that
area down there she wants to create a
garden you know
some sort of God yes lieutenant Gardens
there and she and apparently daniel
smith was supporting that but I think
that's too early to sort of start doing
that because their area is going to be
impounded a little bit and straightened
up a little bit too to facilitate the
roundabout which is going to happen at
Dan Smith scumming off off in side road
want to flex tonight so if you ask my
opinion I think we'd beat her to delay
anything there until that's all done and
put that money elsewhere
just on that Portland I were at the
meeting with Trevor right and and what
top and Dan Smith and it was agreed
there that to do the top and yeah and
heat Dan was going to pay for the trees
so that's going here to Jenny right I
don't know where it's at but that part
is happening regardless of anything else
that was my understanding poor yep okay
so that's that's happening Joan it's not
on hold yeah yeah well that's happening
on its own yeah the question here is
whether you want to put thirty thousand
if that's the recommendation to flex and
whether you want to suggest we put
thirty thousand Seder to Milton
I think that's good enough
Robbie's point would we be wise to set
aside the thirty thousand have grant
MacLeod come to the next meeting and
talk about the options on that thirty
thousand but would that be the best way
forward Mary playing for the random air
at that particular intersection because
I thought if I could have got a plane
and brought the meeting we might have
had something to talk about
there was actually concrete but they're
still working treated design practice in
the ratings got to be done and the drain
is just able to be done so that's over
the next year is there any objection to
asking the grant MacLeod to come to the
next meeting and discuss the thirty
thousand and just put that part on hold
for tonight okay well we'll do that
there seems to be a general consensus
no no we're just going to deal with the
others the other points and then have a
motion that picks them up so you've got
so Robbie you weren't well just make
your suggestion and then we'll pick it
up an emotion yeah
we've already committed to that okay so
is there any disagreement with that by
and large what Robbie's recommending the
errors we prove they put the 30,000 on
hold for the next meeting get a report
back he approves 6000 for the car park
and cast and reject the four thousand
for the rugby posts there's the thirty
thousand yeah
the Flex and Road entrance yeah you
suggested that came right out no no okay
Robbie moves that H goes out and were
you sorry was it approved the twelve
hundred for the poop or not okay
improves is there any general
disagreement with that just one don't
want to debate it but just one of this
general agreement will Robbie will move
there I'm just concerned with of the poo
because it's Ian
landscaping budget as well that should
be a different budget
yeah another best all different bachelor
should commit its reserves that's quite
clear isn't it no Ryan Riley knows it's
it's it's in the right budget yeah it's
a pervert topic all right well I think
we've workshopped it enough
sorry we haven't got the motion yeah we
just clarified coming up now so it's
going what Robbie it what Robbie is
moving correct me if I'm wrong Robbie
and it's not signature when received a
receive the report be notes see approve
is the verb see approves that D notes
e approved 6000 if no it's gone it's
gone so it proves the 30 the allocation
of $30,000 lying on the table - okay
yeah but we've got to deal with it we
need to seek a report on it from green
space otherwise we've got 30,000 no
we're doing nothing okay
you don't want a report on it on Milton
okay okay so to leave out the 30,000 and
approves the allocation of 1200 for pou
pod see clear on that have was seconder
for that segment by Joan right Robbie
open for debate
so just speaking to sorry yep Oh curry
and the nd seconds that I put there to
all those not just a pretty face
Robbi
so by doing this the money's still in
our budget so this the thirty thousand
plus the four thousand for the for the
right B posts and what their money's
still there but it's not allocated to
anything specific so it's going to be up
to grant we've had a deputation tonight
and it's the first I had heard of the
supposin as green space portfolio I
wasn't aware of it and you know it
sounds exciting it sounds great and it
might be something that the board might
want to consider subject to a staff
report at a future time and we've got
that thirty something thousand dollars
sitting in the effort that's what we
choose to do but I'm also very confused
over flexed and Road because I
understood that that road II project was
going to hit going to go ahead now what
I can't 100% guarantee was that it
wasn't put off because of covert and so
I can't keep completely but but I know
that project hasn't disappeared and if
we spend the money
how much does kind of counts we're going
to allocate to us because next year's
LTP is going to be tough yards for this
council how much is going to be
allocated back into the landscape budget
that's the worry of of God if we decide
to put thirty thousand towards Milton
Reserve tonight or some other project
all of a sudden we're cutting our
ability to do something really
constructive in the future so in summary
the money is still there it's still in
our budget that's just we're not
allocating it tonight and the same
applies of the rainy place I do know
that we've poins kuraki they really
wanted some rainy posts posts up there
so I know that's reasonably recent so if
the four thousand will be relevant but I
can't recall
we're from the caste community the
demand came for the Robie posts there
I'm not saying it didn't happen
I just can't can't remember it off the
kaffir at the moment so that's why I've
suggested that come out as well and we
can get a little bit
formation for a future for future media
there's no other than what we've already
committed to and there's a couple things
in here we have we're not in a rush so
it's not Joe I totally concur with
Robbie and yep support exactly what he
says thank you Monique I know I know
Smith has also allocated money to keep
Rainier beautiful to put plantings
around in the flexed android area too so
there's quite a bit of money flowing it
way well in the report ring you're a
keep ring you're a beautiful comment
they don't need money at the moments in
the report here well they sit in a
meeting
that's nice not this month that they
have they've received they're receiving
money from daniel smith yeah yes with
him down near the planting that's create
yeah yeah he was paying for that right
yeah at the speakers well I'll just make
do you want Duncan sort of the motion I
think especially number eight for
example which shows us an opportunity to
support the overhaul of the caste
community secret area I think it's quite
appropriate that we are a party to
rounding off a project is against prep
starting one I think it just puts
another nice polish on the whole resume
fully supportive of them thank you well
I certainly support Robbie's motion I
agree with with what he said it's
unclear exactly what the options are at
the moment as we sit here tonight I was
privileged to and I knew nothing about
Milton until Monday when I went with
staff to meet was mr. right and of
course if he had his way we agreed to it
he wouldn't be doing it the the council
would be doing it board would be making
decisions and things like that but it is
quite an exciting project and I was
surprised from Grant McLeod told me that
the council were already considering it
there was money put aside yeah in in the
budgets who commented Ryan was 80,000 or
something the thirties coming out this
coming year so the board wanted to put
the 30 in it would be help get it
forward or going and that's was his
comments to me now I don't know how
accurate that is and this space and
keeping this money back gives us a
chance to have grant the forest talk
about the issues what's happening get
clarity on flexed and Road and the other
thing so I think that's wise decision
the boards making personally anyone else
but yeah i agree with robbie's some
scenario the I think it's it's wise to
keep it aside just for a rainy day
because we may need it for a rainy day
and yeah and everything else is good
anywhere else
Robbie there's nothing to reply to all
right I'll put that all those in favor
please say right country carried item
thinks thanks Ryan that's that's good
you know item 7.2 we verbally indicated
at the last meeting do you remember the
Lions presented to us and you gave a
verbal indication you were supportive of
this this is to ratify that any
questions of Ryan on this Paul yeah your
what up move by Paul who was sick sick
goodbye Joan do you wish to speak to it
anyone all right good Thank You Joan
I'll put that all those in favor please
say alright country carried items 7.3
this is down-to-earth subject here yeah
pages 39 to 41 who's dealing Murray
that's nice cemetery strategy
development thank you and apologies from
lonely baking South she's in another
meeting tonight
so I've me deputizes to talk to you on
her behalf
I'm actually working with lonely on the
cemetery strategy along with green space
manager grant MacLeod
and it'll be going to Cal
so on the 4th of August and up for
public consultation between the 7th and
31st of August so the cemetery strategy
as as the overarching plan of how the
council's going to manage cemeteries for
the next 20 years and that it's looking
edge have we got a sufficient supply of
land the right type of land are we
meeting what the community is telling us
they require in the way of cemeteries
and also if the council is requested as
it sometimes does to take over
cemeteries or trust symmetry set are
either failing or the organization's
can't maintain them anymore you know
what would be the requirements of the
council prior to agreeing to do that and
the other part of the strategy is just
creating and I guess increased awareness
on you know that the public air they
know what's what the cemeteries are
providing and what the rules and the
operational requirements around them are
and that could be about memorial sizes
that could be about your ashes burial
plots so that's covered in the strategy
and then alongside the strategies is
going to be a cemeteries policy that
will cover some of those operational
aspects and that will be consulted on
separately because it's going to get
into the detail of managing the
cemeteries and there's probably the area
where there's going to be a lot of
public interest
you know we're catering for the
increasing diversity and cultures and
the district are we providing facilities
you know that people are wanting yeah
are the other aspects that that the
community is asking for so the policy's
going to be the more day-to-day
operational parts of that work
any questions questions of Marie you've
convinced everybody obviously well the
document of yet early next month so and
and we believe it is something that
there is a lot of public interest and
well I wish not probably we really won't
Pierre answer it this sifting through
the service had been past me and gone
through the same process with a really
at one thing or not these a cemetery
reserve at stiftung and then there's the
council is also considering another
block of land but there is still and as
a the water table trials I guess is the
way of putting it just yeah so that
still it's too long going any other
questions
we have a recommendation someone
prepared to move it you're very moving
minded tonight move move by move by Paul
seconded by Jason do you wish to speak
to it put that all those in favor please
say aye right confident carried item
seven point for the discretionary grant
pages 42 to 51 k so this is just
information report for you just letting
you know what your balances are on your
discretionary funding and you'll instead
funding so you've got to carry forward
from last year's financial yeah the
leftovers from that so it's boosted your
discretion you found it quite nicely and
as we discussed earlier you've got 53
r61 in the landscaping
in regards to the accountability and
application forms that were discussed in
case you want to do any upgrades the
chairs were quite happy with the
waveforms were working at present asked
a few little changes and we're hoping
that you'll agree and take the rest of
the report as good questions okay okay
someone prepared to move the
recommendations move Robbi seconds by
Joan speak country carried item 8 AB we
won't pages 52 to 56 a is not relevant
at the moment because we haven't
received the memorandum it's the one
that went round earlier but I thought
could you see it we're having a new one
all right so we can receive that right
and we've got what about the visitor
strategy memo
that's right to say um so the visitor
strategy can absolutely valid the blue
just recently and we were asked if it
would be possible for the board to
nominate a representative for two
workshops and I think this is going to
be quite a an interesting workshop and
group to be on because you'll have some
input into how how we're going to
encourage internal visitors to our
district which hopefully will encourage
economy and boost business
so what we're planning to do is find out
if there's any interest from anyone on
the board who would like to be a
representative
then whoever it is we will ratify that
decision at the next meeting is there
anyone that would like to be that
representative now it's there will be a
later meeting as well I was notified I'm
not sure on the date but the first date
is Wednesday the 22nd of July from 10:00
a.m. to 3:00 p.m.
and later on there will be another
similar 5:00 hour so if yet that's
that's alright but there's anyone if no
one else wants to I represent the board
but if some board member wants to their
very welcome all right well know we've
put their hand up so look if you think
about it and you want to give me a ring
otherwise what's up my name there so
that that's all right so on that will
need to move a B and C is the visitor
strategy memo that's tabled so someone
prepared to move that move by Duncan
seconded by Sarah put that all those in
favor please say aye
the country carried chair persons report
I'll I'll move that
seconded by Duncan put that all those in
favor please say aye
contry carried item ten met him those
are for information someone prepared we
receive the information move I don't
concealer by Andy and put that all those
in favor please say hi to the country
carried members information exchange you
will last last time Marisa we'll start
with you this time
can you turn your speaker on so we can
hear had a formal meeting with CDHP the
manager of planning and funding carolyn
gallery over trying to improve the
health services up here in Rainier
particularly with a view to having an
infusion clinic set up at the hospital
that the health happened so people from
regular here didn't have to go all the
way to Emily or to Christchurch to get a
infusion because some of them are
getting an infusion every fortnight
which is you know they seemed fairly
receptive to that idea well it did come
out of it was that there's an intention
by CDHP to bowl the old hospital
building which we knew about anyway and
they're gonna replace that with some
sort of a new building because their old
buildings that only oil - and you only
had to see patients and oil - building
that's for sure and the other thing we
put forward was we noticed that from all
the gray pair meetings I've been to most
of the people being elderly you were
quite upset about having to go all the
way to the ophthalmology or the eye
clinic across hospital and sometimes for
very little so I found out by talking to
regular I cared that they had most of
the equipment there that they had at
Christchurch Hospital anyway and they
were already doing some funded work but
not all of it so I put that to
Canterbury health it'd be a good idea if
they could get bring your eye care take
just a preliminary screener and then it
was anything really serious they can see
never the hospital otherwise the
decedent home again and that means we
wouldn't have to send these people the
hospital all these hassles over
transport and God knows what so they
were quite receptive to that and the
other thing that Jim Pentecost brought
up was the fact that the been a big
reduction in caring sy carers who are
looking after elderly people were in the
district because they reckon there's a
reduction and funding well we found
there from the Canterbury Health Manager
who
present at the meeting that they had
introduced the funding at all but
whatever we happened as nest would
started running out of staff because of
this virus problem so we've managed to
tidy an effort but - so I don't can't
report any warrant so they haven't had a
written report back from them yet
Dean Gordon did a excellent letter to
them which I've got sitting on the
computer at the moment just had to
correct a few things they will be
submitting it in the next day or two by
email as well it's a letter of support I
might need so it's all happening thanks
Marie
oh and the other thing they did say was
the the public health nurses up seas
seed they didn't have a an arene
available to supervise the infusion
clinic but there's one sitting right
next to me thanks Mary
Monique Marie can you turn yours off
please not really much only I'm there
all the time being keep bringing you
beautiful suits well nothing really of
great note sorry Jason so last Friday we
had the wrong notify brigades AGM which
had all of our interesting call-outs for
the year which involved some comic
alternates can't remember many of note
but cats up trees in the middle of the
night was one of them and then on the
18th of June we I attended the
neighborhood supports meeting it sounds
like they're making some pretty good
heat way after the covert with
communities reaching out to connect with
one another and they're looking to some
exciting new campaigns and they're
Canterbury region
so thanks Jason Robbie I think you said
there's been the usual council and
standing committee meetings but what I
wanted to particularly focus on
you need to focus on just near is
something that Morris quite rightly
raised a terror her last meeting and
this would regard to some recycling
issues and I've made the under comic to
Morris the Christchurch of throwing us
under a bus during covert quite frankly
huge head through their communication
strategy by telling people that they
could put general waste into the yellow
burns and there you know there's no way
that we wanted to endorse that because
immediately in breaking habits that have
been built up for years and people are
putting stuff in the yellow burn so they
quite frankly shouldn't have been doing
but here we couldn't go against it and
we of course when we've got to ask the
question here can areas that it's also
put general waste on there in the yellow
burns we issue can because it's all
going to count Valley which the comment
I made when we had the presentation from
cast at the last meeting everything was
going to Kate Valley because echo
central and they closed the doors due to
to lockdown so putting aside the issue
of of cast with regard we go central
they are not going to accept anything
that they cannot get rid of in
contamination levels and you've seen the
articles and the paper are incredibly
high and as a consequence a heck of a
lot of rubbish is recycling is as being
sent because of contamination to kake
Valley so today's solid and hazardous
waste we can some fear but of it was in
committee and Kitty's mention that she's
going through some of that stuff before
she can bring back a a comprehensive
report we obviously we obviously dealt
with the the cast issue you've who the
result of their but also the big focus
of the meeting was the way forward with
regard to recycling a comprehensive
report will be coming to the board the
committee agreed the yes we need to
spend some money on this issue it won't
be out of the right pocket it'll be
aired
the Olivier Livi account this will
involve some serious communications and
we need a comprehensive communication
strategy hopefully that's going to come
together in the next two to three weeks
I know that seems a long time but we're
going to hit this pretty hard with the
the potential that if we're going to get
ordered us out from Christchurch there's
already auditors working for the
Christchurch City Council they're going
to be chicken yellow peoples yellow
birds and we're pushing for you know
three strikes and you're out if you
don't if you don't put in your yellow
bun what you should be putting in your
yellow burn your cheering it up for
everybody you're making it more
expensive for everybody if you can't get
it right we we're not going to give it
yellow better so that's as far as you
know we were very serious meeting this
afternoon this is a very serious issue
which is why I wanted to take this
opportunity to to give you a heads up on
hopefully there's going to be a good
report for the next thanks Morris all
I've got two reporters I attended the
annual ginger me do the ringer Museum
and it was well attended by museum
members
unfortunately I sort of quite an aged
group I would have been the youngest
here until Dan turned up there may mean
not the youngest but now it's a good
meeting and they're a very committed
group of people that are trying
extremely hard to keep the original
museum there and things on display and
it's it's a great asset to the one area
surrounding on using do you think it's
at risk I think in probably five years
time it could be a major risk really
it's just it's a shame that sure one of
our council tours we went to the won't
cooperate
the coracoid Council says and they had
the museum included and that was awful
was actually magnificent yeah it was
really nice it was very accessible to
people if we could only bring the ring
or a museum to part of High Street it
would make a huge difference for
everyone I would think
nd I have been monitoring that
conversation on the council Facebook
page and community Facebook pages the
last week around the state of their
unsealed roads and I think the council
probably needs to I think they're
probably doing something but there needs
to be some communication some play in
there because there's a lot of people
that are pretty frustrated with the was
the set of arrows particularly in Loeb
initially been getting pretty bad so
something's hitting me but yeah it's not
been a busy month for me to be honest
but last week there was a picture of me
and the paper you might have seen it
Shelley taught wanna to sort of make no
and the walking and cycling steering
groupers coming together and I guess
because I run a cycling and walking
group that I have added value to be able
to actually speak to people and get
their thoughts and opinions the paper
articles actually prompted a number of
phone calls which was interesting the
North Canterbury cycling club were very
keen to know why they were not asked and
here for me I've probably wanted the
appropriate people and they want to be
involved in that group had a call from a
couple of people who have a disabled
husband partner wife and they want to
make sure that the access group is
involved which I believe it is they want
to have the essay and what else yeah
that was about it really
yeah well it's been a busy month really
um we started with them adopting the
annual plan and the council initially
and then I've been also on the corporate
accommodation steering room which is
really a
the refurbishments of of this this
property here we will start working
where we work and so then I've also on
the committee of the long term plan and
so we've started using a timeline
together for doing a long term plan
there's going to be lots of work to pull
that together for next March I'm also on
the steering group of the multi sports
stadium we've hit a meeting there and
the stadium is coming along really
really well and I think we're going to
be having a site visit there soon
so there'll be exciting I'm also here a
meeting with the central world drainage
advisory group I'm on that committee as
well so you're finding that really
really interesting so it's sort of
helping and then another meeting with
the chambers footer meeting so that is
just a follow on from the put
accommodation steering group attended
the AGM of regular promotions wrinkle
promotions are very strong and and doing
consolidating this year only going to
have three major functions just focusing
on the when their members and networking
and of course shopping local is really a
feature for everybody and then the next
night I attended the AGM of the
kiteboard promotions so and yes they
have got a jingle going at the moment
and that seems to be I'm getting a lot
of attention also attended the
designation hearing of the Wrangler
airfield which has long awaited was
postponed with Kovich so we'll wait with
bated breath that I think went really
really well but it was very detailed
hearing and then also attended the
Womack eulerian jobs summit that's
Friday morning with bit met do seated so
there's lots of things happening too
progress and support what's happening in
the district and then of course some the
council meeting yesterday was pretty
long when we're signing off on the
annual plan and in various projects so
it's been pretty busy month and it's
gonna be very busy coming up thank you
Paul lucky last yeah like Robbie and
would have been very busy with all this
new council bits and pieces and probably
one of the good things has been just
finished in them bring your own ear as
the safety fence around the sewer ponds
that used to have a seven wire fence and
there's summary in this room has
probably be very happy who have got a
yeah a good security fencing here to
keep some prying mines and people out of
it we have actually had some people when
have gone on there for different reasons
and they were look and see what service
so that's all finished and I've been
involved with the points Road meeting
trying to get this water system together
which is not an easy task and it's going
to it's going to go on for a we wall and
there's going to be some winners and
losers on it and unfortunately this
connect be some some losers and that's
gonna get a bit of feedback on it and
what-have-you with everybody's probably
seen the new water scenario from the
government and the planes in the paper
don't quite know what to make of that
because probably I've been involved with
hurinui water schemes and following
other water skiing with me portfolio of
water we've probably got one of the
better water supplies a New Zealand and
actual effect so if we get designated
with everybody else we might become a
wee bit of a loser on it and my opinion
because then we've probably got a better
schemes then most out of it end
they're trying to propose that they were
going to join a lot of council together
I think there's not only be three for
the whole of the South Island and if
that does happen well I don't know I
personally don't think it's going to be
a good thing for this council because we
maybe we've probably got the bitter
playing field to start with so which is
a weave of a little worried but it's
just mirror watch the space and I think
there'll be a lot of politicking and
before it all happens but it's it's a
wee bit of a worry with the situation
we're in because with points road as
their last water scheme to get over the
line as far as the new regulations are
concerned so we'll be right up to you
saying that live audience debated on the
council near a wee bit of a higher
playing field which were was passed the
last Tuesday's council meeting so and
and it's just a paper working some more
checking on safety factors with water
schemes so then yeah that's just better
watch the space with their water in its
author includes a sewage which involves
the ocean outfall and all that drama
with us and government scheme so it's
it's watch the space really let's see
what happens okay
think thanks Paul Joan I think it might
be a little important I just had another
meeting with either Warwick and we we we
we think we might have saved a vapor
shop coming into in Europe I hope you
have yes and just in confidence in this
row we we int over to see